هل يعيّر الرؤساء بعضهم البعض بالألقاب؟
وبماذا عير صدام حسين حافظ الأسد؟
لم ينس الأسد الموقف،
وهناك بدأت قصة جديدة من الاستفزاز،،
عن الحرب الباردة بين صدام وحافظ الأسد نتحدث وللقصة بقية
في مؤتمر القمة العربية المنعقد في المغرب عام 1982،
احتد النقاش بين الرئيس السوري حافظ الأسد و الرئيس العراقي صدام حسين،
فصدام يرى أن الأسد يقف مع أعداء العراق ضده،
في تلك الفترة كانت هنالك محاولات من الطرفين
لفرض السيطرة على حزب البعث في الدولتين،،،
وبعد أن شتد الجدال بينمها، وارتفعت حدة التوتر،،
قال الرئيس صدام حسين:
لا يحق لك يا حافظ الأسد التحدث في قمة العرب،
و أنت لا تعرف أصلك،
وتحداه صدام أن يذكر له اسم جده الثالث،،،
فكتمها الأسد في نفسه، وظل حاقدا على صدام
ينتظر الوقت المناسب للانتقام،
حتى منتصف الثمانينات، وفي ذلك الوقت تم تنظيم معرض عن حياة السيدة صبحة طلفاح
والدة صدام حسين والتي كانت تعرف بأم المناضلين،
وحضره الكثيرون، وبعد الافتتاح،
تم عرض أغنية الفنان السوري موفق بهجة، وتبدأ
كلمات الأغنية
ب يا (صبحة هات الصينية)
كان من الحاضرون في ذلك المعرض خال صدام خيرالله طلفاح،
وعند سماعه للأغنية، وعلى الفور أحال مديرة المعرض للتحقيق،
وتم عقاب جميع العاملين في المعرض،، وبعد ذلك تم حظر هذه الأغنية في العراق،
ويكفي فقط أن يغنيها أو يسمعها أي شخص في العراق،
ليلقى عقوبته الرادعة في السجن، لما فيها من إهانة لأم المناضلين والدة الرئيس،،،،
وهنا جاءت الفرصة لحافظ الأسد
على طبق من ذهب لينتقم من إهانة صدام له،
عندما علم حرج صدام حسين من هذه الأغنية،
فأمر الأسد التلفزيون السوري أن يتم عرض هذه الأغنية أكثر من مرة في اليوم الواحد،
ليتلذذ بانتقامه عبر إحراج صدام،،
وبعد ذلك أمر الفنان موفق بهجة أن يعيد تصوير الأغنية بعد كان قد تم تصويرها
في عام ١٩٧٣، لم يكتفي الأسد بذلك وجعل طاقم التلفزيون السوري
يبثون الأغنية كل يوم خميس، في برنامج ما يطلبه الجمهور،
وسوآءا أكان بث الأغنية بطلب أو بغير طلب
فلن يمر البرنامج دون عرضها،،
وكان بث التلفزيون السوري يصل لبعض المناطق الحدودية في العراق،
ولكثرة عرض الأغنية على التلفزيون السوري
صار السوريون يلقبون الفنان موفق بهجة ب (يا صبحة)..
الرئيس صدام حسين كان يفاخر بلقبه وعشيرته التكريتية،
وبعد غضبه على الرئيس السوري حافظ الأسد عايره بلقبه،
وهنا كان الرد من الأسد بمعايرة صدام بأغنية فيها إهانة لوالدته
وأنتم متابعونا هل تعرفون مواقف كهذه تحصل بين الزعماء؟
....